Ben Shapiro joins me now editor-in-chief
of daily wire.com that one kind of got
lost in the all of the talk about this
Ben but I know it didn't get lost on you
yeah I mean I thought that was the most
egregious joke of the night I mean it's
it's one thing to go after members of
the administration in even the most
egregious fashion and that happened but
I was really more troubled by the fact
that there are a lot of people in the
audience laughing about a woman openly
joking about the killing of babies and
essentially saying openly that it was
the killing of babies right that joke
was was saying that you need to knock
the baby hard to get it out of there now
a joke is a joke but I'm not sure where
the humor in that lies and I don't think
I'm just being humorless I mean I think
that some of the other jokes that she
told Believe It or Not were kind of
funny that one what I didn't think was
funny at all and again the the fact that
she was saying that you know you don't
don't knock abortion until you try and
substitute slavery for abortion there
and see how funny it is don't knock
slavery until you've tried it and really
when you knock it not get hard because
black people aren't real really people I
mean good yeah this is very awkward and
terrible obviously and evil so it is
amazing so many folks on the Left seem
okay with that so yeah it was such a
awful and strange moment and did prom
some people to get the walkout and other
people to laugh has everybody heard on
that track but it's liberating
apparently for some because Kathy
Griffin says that you know what she's
tired of being nice she's tired of the
fact that she apologized to President
Bush for you know the severed head thing
here she is
it's a year this month that picture was
released right and we already do it it's
been yeah by the way take the apology
back
yeah I meant to say apologize to Trump
but um what do you think about that Ben
well obviously Kathy Griffin's been a
charmer for a very long time it's not
really a shock that the fact that Kathy
Griffin is taking it back now look the
only person who really did well the
other night was Michelle wolf because
we're still talking about her on Monday
and she knows that she knows that
Stephen Colbert did this really nasty
routine in 2005 about President Bush and
now the guy has David Letterman's old
spot and she figures that well there's
gonna be a lot of hit there there's
gonna be a lot of nastiness toward her
young people who are angry at her right
now she figure she'll outlive it the
left will defend her and eventually
she'll be seen as someone who spoke
truth to power and from the most
powerful people in the world even though
I'm sorry but speaking in front of a
bunch of leftist journalists said at a
cocktail party is not exactly
Solzhenitsyn type stuff yeah I mean you
know nobody really cares in most of
America what goes on at that dinner
that's for sure but you know you look at
these dinners and you wonder you know
sort of what happened to roasting I mean
in my mind roasting is sort of an
acerbic embrace it's supposed to make
everybody feel like they kind of get the
funny things that are annoying about
each other and that roasting is an art
but that is not what we saw on Saturday
night that's right and again you know if
she wants to most members of the Trump
administration who can't get up and say
anything back like Sarah Huckabee
Sanders I think it's pretty nasty by the
same token for the White House to
complain about you know a nasty comic
when President Trump has said some
things I think is a little bit
ridiculous but it by the at the exact
same time for the media to rip on
President Trump for the stuff he said
and then to defend Michelle wolf for the
stuff she said